[Music]
I'm not sure how much I can necessarily
talk about can't do like final yeah I
mean I don't think I can say exactly
what I think of it but I can definitely
answer a lot of questions that people
might have about it people are curious
about this game yeah
like obviously the big deal is that they
took a year off after syndicate finally
took some rest from the franchise which
has been yearly since FSS 72 was it when
they became 303 was and I love the
series up until 3 I think that's where I
started to falter but then I also like
Black Flag but not for Assassin's Creed
reasons but my main question is again I
was hundreds review will be up sometime
soon ish in the next couple days but I
want to talk to you about someone who
was beaten the game played all of it or
just laid like 20 hours or something I
didn't finish the game unfortunately
like we had to go somewhere else to play
it oh yeah
however I did I I think I probably
finished 2/3 of it maybe a little bit
more explored most of the world which is
by far the coolest thing about this game
yes is the setting I mean northern
Africa
yeah and that's always been a staple of
Assassin's Creed is the setting it's
always kind of taken the forefront of
the experience however just seeing Egypt
I think is so cool yeah you can before
we're going more to that you can go
outside of Egypt right isn't it all
their parts of northern Africa as well
because it's not it's not it's like
Cleopatra Julius Caesar era right you
can go outside of the bounds of Egypt
correct I believe so I mean the map is
huge the map the map is very big like I
think Alessandra who finished it even
said that he didn't the story didn't
take him everywhere yeah but I'm pretty
sure you can go outside of Egypt but I'm
not entirely sure certain okay
but yeah the map itself one thing
obviously you could see if you're
watching this live you could see like a
Skyrim mask compass up there rather than
the old mini-map on all the other
assassin's creed's which just became
littered with kind of menial tasks left
and right in question marks and
exclamation points and collectibles and
side quests that just ended up being
fetch quests but how does that feel in
this game as far as exploring does it
feel like it's living up to what Ubisoft
has been
that they're trying to focus more on
exploration or encourage you to explore
rather than just going to the next
Waypoint yeah I would say so I
I particularly really like that compass
up there I think it does do a good job
of kind of keeping your eyes focused on
what's around you rather than what's in
the corner yeah
and seeing the question marks up there
is definitely enticing if you get near
something like ah I wonder what this is
I'll go check it out
however it's not for some reason it's
not it's it's it's not as enticing to
explore as it was in Skyrim for me at
least like it wasn't like ooh I wonder
what this is I'm gonna go check this out
kind of when I got on a path or when I
had an objective I looked to see where
it was and just headed in that direction
I wasn't always like oh I'm deviating
from the path I guess you could say yeah
and that's kind of there also adding to
the combat in this game usually it's
like a tack counter kind of contextual
this game they went more like actually
active you could dodge and there's a
light attack and there's I mean I played
a little bit of it it's a block light
attack power the heavy attack she'll
break or whatever you wanna say how does
that all feel within like like I know
you played it in review events before or
sorry preview events but how does it
feel overall like as you're maybe
upgrading Biak your character and
everything does actually feel like the
combat is more like a bigger focus of
the game this time around or I still
feel kind of like an afterthought it it
feels like a bigger focus of the game
and it has moments where it is a lot of
fun mm-hmm
like what I've been saying is in
controlled environments it's really cool
like if you're in a flat area you're not
overwhelmed being able to like you know
focus more on making contact with an
enemy kind of pulling the trigger when
you want to attack is a lot more
involved and interesting however the the
camera is one example like if you're in
a tight core tight quarters and you're
fighting someone it is now damn it can
be tough or if you're being attacked by
a lot of people and and you're messing
with the control stick your your your
lock-on will just fly all over the
screen right in Alessandra saying a lot
of times he would just turn off his
lock-on and that would solve a lot of
the issues which you can't do however I
think when you turn off the lock on it
feels even it feels floaty mm-hmm so I
don't particularly like doing that but
yeah in close quarters
is it is very difficult what's going on
sorry it's the most capable camel I've
ever seen I like that you're riding a
camel
yeah a camel that's like those seen in
the mummy when Brendan Fraser and I
start sprinting across the desert and
they win because the camels have better
stamina that's what I was thinking too
yeah yeah Brendan Fraser I forget
someone it was it Ben back from John
Baum he just randomly tweeted Brendan
Fraser's battlegrounds the other day
hello i think i think i did see that i
liked it um what about byuk is he a
likable character from what you've
played yeah likable the rock well no
like was worried sick from unity yeah I
don't my didn't play syndicate enough
the evie frye
and big up fry is that correct camels
but it's so plebeian Jacob I could be
wrong I think it's Evie and Jacob yeah
but I didn't play syndicate but I like
by X so far yeah night Magi he's a Magi
he he is very serious and at first he
comes across as Syria so when I started
playing I was like great we're gonna
have another very serious kind of
brooding assassin's creed or whatever
yeah which he kind of is to an extent
but there are definitely moments of
lightheartedness like there's a couple
missions where they're like children or
whatever and he'll like I don't know
kind of play around with the children
it's kind of nice seeing a little more
depth to this character as opposed to
yeah Connor who's just kind of brooding
just a cold murderer who never feels
anything yeah I mean he's still a cold
murder so there's people asking on
Twitter so Tom Merritt earlier today I
responded to me saying what new features
Assassin's Creed offering for fans who
have become labor the series that may
draw them back in so people that like
it's not their first Assassin's Creed
like myself of any of the features that
you mentioned kind of or the additions
were the revamps what are there any that
are gonna bring in veteran players who
might have kind of gotten tired after
syndicate like with a two year break
helpful I think the two year break was
helpful I think the biggest thing for me
at least is how open the world is it and
how it focuses more on exploration
rather than a sort of hub area where
you're completing isolated missions
instead
you go to an entirely new area just
because you know you've traveled over
there you find some missions just at
your leisure you do them maybe you get
halfway through a mission you don't like
it you go to a different one so I think
that adds a lot more player choice than
we've seen in previous games and I think
that could draw people back in I think
the combat is also fun in those certain
I mean it can be frustrating but I think
early on I think fans will enjoy the new
style of combat stealth too like I mean
still like as an assassin can you still
yeah there's stealth I I don't think
it's great to be fair I never thought
the stealth in Assassin's Creed games
are that great now and I don't think
this one is any better I know how
Alessandro and Matt we're kind of saying
it may not even be quite as good and but
I don't wanna speak too much to what
they thought of it but I mean to me it
seemed like just Assassin's Creed combat
you sneak behind enemies and you stab
them but I think the biggest thing that
might have people interested is the loot
system I know a lot of people play RPGs
and games like this for loot and now as
you play you will be getting differently
you'll be levelling up by AK and it
feels more like a character progression
in terms of abilities and level rather
than you know you just get a new unit
you get a new piece of tech or something
like that it's a little bit more fleshed
out I'd say in terms of that it's the
loot system like well-designed like I
mean cuz shadow of war had a loot system
obviously that drew some controversy but
it felt tacked on and shadow of war does
it feel actually essential to the
experience here it's abaya I don't think
it feels tacked on it but it's not
nearly as in-depth as something like
destiny or Diablo cuz most of the
weapons feel the same it's not like
destiny where you get an exotic gun that
feels completely different from another
exotic gun right I mean you get a
legendary axe and it'll feel like all
the other axes except there is a perk to
it always in damage or something
yeah poison damage or you'll regain
health on every hit or something like
that okay but still just seeing like a
gold weapon drop you like oh I wonder
what this is and you click on it like it
is it is entertaining to see what you
get as you play like your your spear
here is glowing this is probably one of
the perks here
so like yeah that and what's the point
of fighting hippos self-defense because
they attacked people and kill them your
resources from right yeah lumber can so
it's it is very Ubisoft in the sensor
it's like oh you an upgrade your gear go
hunt so you go boom hippo skin yeah get
some hippos skin because you know
nothing you know nothing's stronger than
hippo skin on right yes yeah right is
there a do they push you play stuff a
lot or is it just like any other Ubisoft
game it's just there and the menus it
seems like it's just there in the menus
I think while I was playing I got like
one or two you play achievements
actually no I don't think I did an
assassin's creed I'm thinking maybe
South Park is didn't tell her it was
yeah it was pretty heavy-handed in South
Park okay I'm off the bat it starts off
and it's like here or someplace Star
Trek Online or star sure yeah it's
marketing but like no like you start off
in South Park and it's like login to you
be play if you want to wear this
Assassin's Creed outfit and whatever was
I don't know and then yeah you're
getting a lot of prompts in South Park
here here it's not as often doesn't
doesn't seem as bad to be honest I don't
think I saw any notifications for you
play or anything like that you can go to
the in-game store and I think you can
purchase points in order to purchase
different outfits and weapons sure but
when I was in there I already had like
or I think we were playing on yeah I
already had like 750 or something like
that and I don't know how I got him but
I did so it seems like there are ways to
get those points other ways than paying
but you know yeah still you can pay to
get that cool stuff if you want do
you're talking a little bit about side
quests stuff because yeah that's
something I want to say it pulled me
away from Assassin's Creed games was
getting that fatigue of like you know I
think I've done this about 50 times and
you know some of the you know the
outside side quest activities were very
they felt a little cut in pay C's can
you can you vouch for that here or is it
less of it is it still present would you
say it's it's still present but I would
say less of it yeah they're they they do
a good job of giving context to side
mission okay that's cool for the most
part like
you end up you hit a point where you get
basically get gated to move on and you
have to do a lot of them and when I did
that I was like alright I don't really
care what this mission is about I just
wanna get it done so I can get to the
next area mm-hmm or get to the next like
story beep sure but like there are
definitely missions that are far more
interesting than what I played in the
older Assassin's Creed games in terms of
side quests however when you do talk to
an NPC when you get something like this
it's really hard to pay attention to
what's going on just cuz it's like I
don't know the the character's eyes are
like dead and lifeless and they're not I
don't know just it's not exactly pretty
to look at when you're in these little
conversations wasn't there also
something they were like pushing was
like all the NPC's have like how do you
say like set like time of day would like
waypoints a jewelz schedules and stuff
would was that noticeable or stalk
someone for like two hours yeah when you
get your bird I'll be sweating right now
just going on sweating talking about
stalking people when you're getting
excited oh so here's the bird right now
but the bird you can look at enemies and
it'll say what they're doing actually I
may not have oh yeah talking so you can
kind of see like alright he's I don't
know eating or something like that
pooping thinking like gotcha now that
now's the time to kill him because he's
pooping totally but I mean you can
completely ignore those and you won't
notice the difference like I like it was
more the thing where I fly and I'm like
I he's he's distracted I guess now is
the time to kill him as opposed to some
other time but I'd still kill him anyway
because it was the objective no
multiplayer there oh there there there
is there's like a connectedness to it I
don't know how much I can talk about it
but it's not like you're actually facing
off against other players mm-hmm cool so
this is out tomorrow October 27th
alongside Super Mario - Friday right all
right a today's Wednesday sorry October
27th Friday alongside Super Mario
Odyssey and Wolfenstein 2 new Colossus
[Music]